pues sí lamentable este accidente en el
que hasta ahora se sabe un saldo
preliminar de 49 personas muertas y 59
lesionados se trata de un vehículo de
carga en el que viajaban más de 100
migrantes en condiciones de hacinamiento
y al parecer el conductor del vehículo
iba a exceso de velocidad lo que provocó
que se desprendiera la caja donde
viajaban y el impacto provocó la muerte
de estas
de estas decenas de migrantes que en su
mayor son guatemaltecos las víctimas de
hecho el tener que lamentar este
accidente y ofrece la ayuda consular
incluidas las repatriaciones a las que
haya lugar de igual manera el instituto
nacional de inmigración de méxico ha
informado que ella está en coordinación
para brindar la asistencia consular así
como la identificación de los cuerpos y
cubrir los gastos funerarios de las
personas que perdieron la vida y
facilitar la repatriación tanto de
cuerpos como de sobrevivientes asimismo
se brindará atención humanitaria que
consiste en alojamiento alimentación a
quien así lo desee
otorgamiento de tarjetas de visitante
por razones humanitarias
el director del instituto mexicano del
seguro social también ofreció atención
médica a través de la delegación en
chiapas de los hospitales del imms para
las personas que se encuentran lesionada